i wanted it do you want to see oh i saw
this
you saw this yeah okay i i backed up a
little bit before the time stamp because
it's worth it can i set this up a little
bit though go ahead all right so
look we've we've had our diagnosis of
stephen crowder for some time
very wound up very much a control freak
very much a guy that despite his
expert levels of
sort of hiding the rage and and that
that just wound up like he's
there's a mean nasty part of crowder
that he never lets you see
and he's just you can tell he's he's
just a dick and uh yeah they were
having some fun they were they were
hanging out having some fun
so i backed it up about a minute before
the incident so you could kind of see
what what led up to it okay
so here we go what happened stephen
one old guy pushes another old guy you
know
mr clyburn uh double permanent
uh push it push it good which reminds me
push it real good would have been the
joke yeah seriously
he's not he doesn't do a great trump
just looking up before we get to this
the old old guy who was shoved down by
police officers and donald trump tweeted
about it
um six nine this guy
nice i started i just
that's not even the first time steven
crowder said six nine this guy
this week that day he was just
describing what happened off the air
so now i want you to notice everyone
everyone noticed his rage start building
up
the mask falls off as it were
six nine this guy i started i just went
down the road horrible we're not
we're not the old people and we go like
this is really bad like
people would say to us because we
listened to you know punk rock like
anti-flag or something
there was still some semblance of there
was a bridge of musical connection yeah
right to now this six nine characters
i don't know that i've heard anything
from mr six nine it's just
literally one of his lyrics is pop pop
pop dot
that's one of the things cause he's just
looking for a rhyme oh okay and when you
just think about how far we've gone to
like every one of these videos is just
just it's just asses and like and i
always say by
i'm just saying like literally it's
women pressing their buttocks
against a man's crotch area
you prefer man disgusting awful you
prefer men
now whenever we want to focus here this
the canadian psychopath's about to come
out
like well no it's not culture because
there's no way you don't know
people go over it goes back to elvis
listen we can go back to the beatles and
i want to
shut up please just once for crying out
loud i'm trying to say something jill
just keeps talking
what is it that you're saying
you know the last guy that talked over
crowder
wow you know the last guy that talked
over old
the canadian psychopath wow
what's up you see that anger do you see
it you see that anger see it behind his
eyes
we've been trying to tell you guys you
know he's got a [ __ ]
oh that boy's got a dark side to him
look and look at his face because he
know look i don't know what the guy's
name is i don't know what's producer's
name but i really don't watch crowder
but you could tell that he's he's the uh
behind those
eyes is oh [ __ ] i'm getting a talking to
after the program
oh yeah he is not a
happy man
yeah i'm gonna let me just i want to see
if we get the moment we're gonna here we
go here
because there's no way you don't know
when people go oh it goes back to elvis
listen we can go back to the beatles and
i want to shut up please just once for
crying out loud i'm trying to say
something chill just keeps talking
what is it that you're saying i said
jeez oh okay
[Laughter]
i was supporting you before that have
you seen the the crotch rubbing with the
butts
no okay i've said geez it's
there is a [ __ ] i thought you said i
was okay crowder
he is so tightly wound up
he is ready to pop at any moment and the
addies don't help
nah they don't okay i'm trying to
educate you
and bridge the cultural divide do you
not want to hear about crotch rubbing
with butts
i i don't this feels like a trigger
aren't you married
it's a it's a very weird energy now
right it's a very weird energy that you
feel in this or in that room
and they got to finish the show they're
just right 10 minutes to do a [ __ ]
hour-long show
joey pesci goes in crowder's defense
jeez is like the n-word to a canadian
it's true that's all right i know that's
all right this was a worker 10 minutes
into
a an hour an hour-long show
oh man that's gotta have to be a rough
day for them
uh and uh by the way because i'm i'm
actually
i'm being told that i need david p sent
this clip in
so everybody could pee on david p yes
peony on david
peon david i do like uh he's doing
another dress-up thing it's pajama day
mm-hmm
oh yeah yeah this is pajama day always a
dress-up theme there's always a
like i'd [ __ ] quit this show if they
if that became a thing
no i'm not i'm not doing that you guys
can do whatever the [ __ ] you want
i'm coming into work tomorrow sombreros
we're gonna do a [ __ ] dress up no
we're not
sombreros i wouldn't even care it's just
a hat it's a hat it's a stupid hat
fake mustache was fine but like they'd
dress up in like
theater level costumes and i'd be like
no i'm not doing this
i don't even do it on halloween it's
called being a grown-up stephen come on
yeah to get you in trouble with your
wife um
so no it's not cultural you go back to
the beatles and i want to hold your hand
you can find
any society you can go to egyptian
hieroglyphics and see people holding
hands
even though like afternoon delight it's
still about a lover
and wanting to engage in making love
with a lover
a little bit more modern remember how
how controversial salacious salt and
pepper were
it was push it push it real good now
it's just
rubbing my ass on your crotch my my back
i'm like oh my god ugh this is gonna be
someone's wedding song
let's sing the rest of it yeah crowder
can you i want to hear the rest of
my [ __ ] in my crack come on let's hear
it [ __ ] song by the way
is is he about put it in his mouth
he's kind of a boomer man like he's a
[ __ ] man
that's a better one yeah well he's
i don't he is here's the thing
he's wound up in my opinion i want to
say him i want to stress
in my opinion of course a tightly wound
up closet visual man who's
also really really hopped up on [ __ ]
pharmaceutical speed
who's a control freak and a bit of a
sociopath
um he's so boxed into this world he had
to make for himself
that i don't think he's a boomer i think
he has to just pander to them
and i i think that his his being
bothered by this kind of stuff
is for the same reason that um you see
somebody sent a clip last the other
night to night wave of
nick fuentes talking about the time some
girl hit on him at some event
and the way he's discussing it he has
this disgust in his voice
that it was gross lust in her eyes and
it was great he was talking about it
like it was the grossest thing ever in
the world
and it there is a certain element of
you know when when you're when you're
gay and you're not okay with it
that you get really like go [ __ ] all
sex is great it's disgusting
yeah it's degenerate because it all like
if you see a chick
you know giving a doodle lap dance
you're going to
not enjoy that but you're going to start
thinking like man what if that was a
dude giving a laughter it still
unlocks sexy thoughts in your head and
then you're they just go ah
gross that's my theory it's just my
theory anyway
well uh i mean that's pretty much it
with this clip there's really not
i'm not going to sit here and watch any
more crowder than i need to watch like
why would i put our fans through this
that's why they watch us and not him for
the most part
true just wanted to show you that little
oh yeah back in the [ __ ] house
and he's been doing a morning show too
he's been doing a morning show and an
afternoon show now he probably needs
that money he just doesn't want to be
home
all right that and i just i don't think
he's making as much money as he is do
you think so
i don't think he's he's not he's on a
decline he's not
he's not going up he's not reaching any
new people he's not expanding his
audience he peeked in about
he peaked during the culture war days
2017
if i had to guess either 2017 or 2018
was crowder's banner year
where he made crazy money and he was the
most famous he's ever been
i don't think there's a new like this
culture wars [ __ ] it has a [ __ ]
there's a there is a [ __ ] there's a
ceiling to that
you know he's i think he's reached just
about everybody he's gonna reach
he's not gonna get any normies and he's
not gonna get any like left wing
he's not gonna get any progressives to
listen to him so yeah i think he's
reached the ceiling
and i think he's got to do more shows
now